[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission qui
allie alimentation agriculture écologie
mais aussi politique et cette semaine et
bien c'est jean françois piège qui va
passer sur le grill est avec moi pour
présenter cette émission jean pierre
montanay bonjour jean pierre bonjour
brigitte bonjour jean françois piège
bonjour bonjour jean françois piège vous
êtes chef cuisinier multi-étoilé vous
avez fait vos classes auprès des plus
grands christian constant yves
candeborde eric fréchon ou alain ducasse
ce qui vous ouvre les portes du plazza
vous avez même fait votre service
militaire au palais de l'elysée c'était
sous mitterrand so chic aujourd'hui vous
êtes à la tête de plusieurs restaurants
comme le cover green recovery la poule
au pot le mimosa et puis surtout le
grand restaurant où vous possédez 2
étoiles le graal mais pourquoi donc
avoir emprunté ce nom au film de louis
de funès ou le patron et et tyrannique
avec ses employés et obséquieux avec ses
clients alors sans doute un acte manqué
pour celui qui rêvait déjà du petit
écran où l'on peut vous voir dans top
chef j'espère que le jury fera preuve
d'indulgence aujourd'hui jean-pierre
pour le menu du jour est alors venue des
tomates farcies vont elles résister au
crash test mystère encaisseur une tarte
aux pommes dans le dos ou des plats le
guide michelin a déclenché une guerre
des étoiles tous veulent faire partie et
clan très restreint dernière élu
frédéric calmels il vient de décrocher
sa première étoile au favori le
restaurant des sources et de cheverny
dans les pieds dans le plat faut-il
encore manger du gras le débat fait rage
depuis que jean françois piège là banni
de sa cuisine allez on passe à table
tout de suite cuisine et confidences
jean-françois vous portez bien votre nom
parce qu'avec brigitte on s'est dit
l'invité en fait c'est le piège oui
facile je sais pas si la salle on vous
l'a déjà fait j'imagine mais non on les
refait on est un peu running gag avec
votre kyrielle des toiles votre cv de
cuisinier long comme un jour sans gras
vos dix saisons comme juré de top chef
sur m6 où vous pouvez gentiment
dézinguer on s'est dit mais quelle idée
on a bien il va exiger un plat de palace
impossible à réaliser il va nous
humilier et jetés sur cette émission-là
frau qui va nous coûter nos places à
tous les deux et bien non pas du tout
voilà que vous cinq fois toqués au gault
et millau vous nous réclamer on se passe
des tomates farcies oui à plat de
cantoche alors ouf trois fois ouf et
bien passé sur brigitte car c'est là le
piège c'est votre plat préféré
les tomates farcies de votre maman
autant dire qu'on touche à l'intimé au
sacré brigitte on est mort j'appréhende
tellement sa première bouchée d'autant
que le chef a changé de doctrine sur les
tomates j'ai encore quelques années il
fallait voir sa farce avec du fromage de
l'huile d'olive et puis le zéro gras est
passée par là donc farce désormais
riquiqui un peu de viande mais pas trop
un peu plus et vous êtes capable ou pas
mais pas que 1 oui bakker normes jeudi
un peu plus il est même capable de les
retenir de tofu de kinois je me trompe
jean françois piège non je pense que la
cuisine la loi d'être varié c'est pour
ça que j'en ai fait cet ouvrage j'ai
fait un ouvrage 0 grâce parce que pour
ceux qui n'ont pas envie de manger de
gras ils peuvent manger correctement
avec et puis j'ai fait celui-là allez
dire que manger du gras dont vous êtes
en cuisine et surtout c'est le chiffre
sais c'est que de la cuisine en fête moi
je les écris pas je les cuisine les
livres donc je fais les recettes et il
ya des gens pour les experts alors ça
c'est la recette préférée de votre maman
c'est celle qu'elle vous cuisiner c'est
ma recette préférée c'est que quand on
avait envie de me fin quand j'étais plus
jeune quand on a envie de faire plaisir
c'était de manger de tomates farcies
alors est ce que vous voulez goûter by
plaisir comment vous les trouvez déjà à
la lueur bon alors s'il allure on parle
de la lure comme ça visuellement c'est
pas la tres le le meilleur mais est-ce
que non mais c'est pas ça je préfère
avoir une tomate qui est déstructurée
parce qu'elle va être cuite est
concentrée en goût comme une tomate qui
est parfaite qui va pas être cuite donc
laisser réchauffer donc à l'ordre du
jour parce qu'elle a été réchauffé
l'adhérence et donc les cuisines sont
pas ici mien non et puis j'ai demandé un
plat conférence en général plutôt en
pleine saison des tomates
effectivement là on est un peu hors
saison ce qu'on va combattre totalement
dans la cuisine mais c'était l'idée en
fait de parler de cette cuisine qui
m'est cher c'est la cuisine du sentiment
parce que je pense que la cuisine ça
doit être que du sentiment ça doit être
fait pour faire plaisir nous notre parti
c'est le parti du plaisir en fait les
cuisiniers et quand on demande à un
membre de sa famille qu'est ce qui te
ferait plaisir effectivement on va
choisir dans ce qu'il aime j'ai choisi
les tomates farcies et se plaint on le
retrouve dans les cartes de vos
restaurants ça c'est vraiment un pelage
de famille qu'on déguste c'est vraiment
un plat de lentilles c'est vraiment on
est vraiment dans ce que j'aime bien
manger parce qu'en général on m'a juste
ont mangé ça chez moi quand on les
mangeait un pot-au-feu et puis comme si
on mettait les restes on mettait les
reste dedans et c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui dans cette situation qui est
un petit peu plus compliqué au niveau du
budget qu'on arrive peut-être à réduire
son budget pour la nourriture c'est de
cuisiner les restes ça fait partie de la
cuisine française lemire au thon la
tomate farcie
il y en a beaucoup je pense qu'il faut
savoir faire des plats on prend
peut-être un peu plus de temps à
réaliser mais on sait qu'on va les
réutiliser donc en termes de coûts on va
diminuer le coût et en termes de plaisir
va pas diminuer parce que comme on la
cuit deux fois on a concentré les goûts
on a des choses moi j'adore j'ai pas aux
dames contraire j'adore mais alors votre
maman elle avait un petit truc pour wii
vers la tomate farcie oui et je vais
c'est petit mais je vois d'ailleurs qui
n'en sont pas très loin pourquoi ne
quittez pas de la chair à saucisse
c'était le reste d'un plat
oui et dans lequel donc comme la viande
étaient cuites elles n'étaient pas
amalgamer elle était très moelleuse pas
d'oeuf dedans pour pas la serre est très
moelleux et je préfère une farce qui est
moins tenu une farce qui est plus
mauvaise qu'une farce qui est très belle
mais qui est un peu dure à manger et il
a autant de succès chez vous aujourd'hui
ce plat en famille les enfants sont trop
jeunes encore pour arriver à une petite
fille qui avait un moi et j'ai un petit
garçon qui a 6 ans qui sont pas encore
dans dans ses goûts la de cuisine mais
j'espère qu'ils le seront très
prochainement et vous l'avez revisité
vous cette tomate farcie ce qui marche
en leur visite jamais on laisse dans
l'état où c'est la tradition j'aime bien
faire une cuisine singulière aux grands
espaces une cuisine singulière c'est à
dire une cuisine qui m'appartient quand
on a la poule au pot à l'épi d'or où on
est dans des bistrots qui ont des
identités très française j'aime ne pas
re visiter c'est à dire qu'ils ont bien
mangé une soupe à l'oignon si on vient
manger une poule au pot j'ai pas cherché
à rajouter quelque chose qui
m'appartient par en fait ça appartient à
qu'une française donc on essaye de le
nez des passeurs on essaye de le passer
dans l'état où il doit être c'est sympa
aussi des tomates farcies c'est que
c'est un éventail très large aprilia
voilà après n'y a pas de recette sur
celle là il n'y a pas de recette alors
moi je vous dire trois petites choses à
savoir que van persie alors d'abord il
faut choisir des tomates plutôt grosses
comme celles de marmande ou alors les
corps de boeuf ou la variété ferline
bien vide et brigitte de leur cher que
vous gardez à côté et afin d'éviter que
les tomates neurones de l'eau on laisse
aller on les retourne sur un grill comme
ça sur une grille elles vont un peu se
rajouter une petite chose allez-y oui
quand on les vide il ya des à
l'intérieur et des croisillons oui si on
les enlève oui elles ont tendance à
tomber sur les gardes elle reste là ça
peut le squelette de la tomate
exactement surtout en le vide avec le
bout des doigts et on enlève pas c'est
s'est petitement bande a intérêt à faire
attention aussi de ne pas la percée en
bas souvent quand on arrache trop vite
savoir si on peut faire un petit trou
donc on les salons les retourne sur une
grille alors la farce c'est la grande
question elle doit être compact sans
être sèche mais jean-françois aime bien
aussi qu'elle soit un peu un pas trop
trop serré personnellement je mélange
toujours le boeuf ou le veau avec du
porc plus gras qui va apporter un peu de
moelleux après on peut rajouter la
chaire de tomates des oignons du persil
d'hamid pas moi j'aime bien y ajouter
aussi des feuilles de blettes voyez un
oeuf un peu de fromage le riz je ne suis
pas fan souvent on trouve dur il en est
vrai parfum alors c'est souvent des
recettes un peu ottomane turc nature
font beaucoup de légumes farcis avec du
riz à l'intérieur pour la cuisson les
disposer dans un plat à gratin
avec un peu d espace entre elles j'ai
cru comprendre que jean françois piège
lui préféré qu'elle soit un peu à touche
touche pour qu'elle reste un peu qu'on
reste un peu qu'elle se tient prête si
on les sert un peu elle va en laisser
plus longtemps au four donc en restant
plus longtemps au fond elles vont cuire
un peu plus longtemps elles seront plus
concentrés en goût d'accord donc je
reviens et je les aimais l'idéal vous
savez quoi c'est dans mon dernier
restaurant j'ai mis un faux un feu de
bois et une fois qu'on a utilisé le feu
de bois qu'on a engrangé en défendant
c'est-à-dire cool le four évident quand
on s'en va on existe dedans ça va cuire
tout doucement
voilà alors versé un peu d'huile d'olive
sur le plat puis on les au four d'alors
180° pendant 40 minutes à peu près et
puis on rajoute au dernier moment dans
les dix dernières minutes les petits
chapeaux pour parce que si on met le
chapeau trop tôt il a tendance un peu à
troc alias état et puis tout à l'heure
on disait belle ne vont pas être chaudes
elles vont être froide mais à nice par
exemple il ya la culture du petit farcie
avec des tomates farcies et bien on les
mange très froide et cet excellent l'été
et on met un peu plus de légumes dedans
voilà il ya beaucoup de blade d'épinards
voilà exactement souvent quand on les
mange froide il ya un petit peu moins de
viande et un petit peu plus de légumes
ce qui donne beaucoup de mal et aussi et
beaucoup de goût et les faux sourds sur
les plus petites tomates que des grosses
tomates farcies c'est un peu la tomate
farcie française qu'on retrouve chez les
traiteurs les italie les niçois ils sont
plutôt sur des toutes petites tomates et
même parfois s'il ya un reste de
ratatouille on mais serait ce de
ratatouille avec de la viande qui est
déjà cuites on mélange on peut mettre le
dos ben voilà où un reste de dôme aussi
ça c'est mais il garde parce qu'ils font
des raviolis dogues ont parlé de lorient
alors ça c'est le plat qu'on va trouver
à la maison mais vous vos plats
signature j'ai lu qu'il y avait la pizza
soufflé à la mozzarella fumée oui pizza
souffler c'est un plat que je fais chez
clover donc moi j'ai plusieurs j'allais
dire j'ai plusieurs cuisines parce que
j'ai pas de restaurant identité chez
clover il ya une pizza souffler il ya
des calamars carbonara c'est une cuisine
qui est un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus large en dehors de la cuisine de la
poule au pot ou là on est très français
et aux grands restaurants très singulier
aux grands restaurants blanc manger
c'est l'île flottante de ma grand-mère
s'évade dessert signature oui c'est mon
dessert signature elle est partie sans
transmettre la recette dont vous savez
cette madeleine de proust ou ce goût que
j'ai connu dans mon enfance je n'ai
jamais pu leur hôtel à la recherche de
ce goût échouent à la recherche de ce
goût et donc à un moment donné je me
suis libéré de ce sentiment pour créer
mon une photo qui est en fait un
unis flottante inversé ou le la crème
anglaise est à l'intérieur et c'est le
dessert que je sers à tous mes convives
quand il vient de manger aux grands
restaurants
c'est mon histoire en fait c'est ça
quand je dis c'est singulier c'est ce
qui est en moi que j'essaye de faire
vivre à mes convives quand de mon corps
qu'est ce qui vous inspire aujourd'hui
la première chose c'est la nature donc
la saisonnalité la régionalité à travers
sa culture propre comme figuré c'est
pour ça que je fais une cuisine des
territoires de france au grand
restaurant en ce moment on fait une
langoustine qui est cuisiné avec des
algues que qui sont ramassés au croisic
par un ramasseur d'algues incroyable
dans la sphère à la mode des algues
c'est très bon pour la santé c'est très
bien oui et puis il y en a surtout quand
on est face il s'appelle jean marie
pedro quand on est face à des
professionnels qui ramassent des algues
sublime qui sont pas celles qui traînent
sur le banc la vraie vie d'avant c'est
pour ça je peux permettait de dire ça
qui les mettent dans des bassins de
décantation on a des goûts mais
incroyable élan la cuisine au beurre
elle ça se mange comme si on mangeait
des épinards à la crème et c'est que des
algues avec une noisette de beurre salé
et c'est pour ça que je dis
j'essaye de glorifier les territoires
dans ma cuisine parce qu'en fait la
culture elle se fait aussi à travers les
tendances le beurre salé n'existe
probablement qu'en bretagne est pourquoi
je cuisine les ags au beurre salé parce
qu en fait j'essaye de prendre ce qui
provient de la bretagne est aussi la
façon de faire la culture aux profs
savoir faire et les produits exactement
et les voyages aussi vous inspire parce
que là vous parlez des produits bruts
qui vous inspire metz que les voyages
les expériences ou même d'aller de
manger dans un autre restaurant que le
vôtre est-ce que de temps en temps pour
aller tirer une petite histoire une
petite idée qui peut vous inspirer pour
une recette plus élaborées à la piège
alors pour grand restaurant c'est que
singulier pour les autres ça fait partie
de chaque histoire le la poule au pot ya
aucune de mes recettes c'est que des
recettes de cuisine française en fête au
grand restaurant on essaye d'être
singulier on ne fait que ça en ce moment
on m'a difficultés avec le temps qui
fait à trouver des mauries seller
mourillon qui pousse on n'a pas cherché
à trouver des mauries ailleurs qu'en
france on a plus in et des morillons
donc quand je vous dis que c'est la
nature qui dicte la cuisine c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire dire que votre
carte est en perpétuelle évolution
totalement
changer très très régulièrement en
fonction de l'arrivée des produits de la
saisonnalité ils s'aspergent avait
commencé vous avez remarqué que depuis
dix jours il ya une vague de froid qui
est qui a tombé sur sur la france et les
grosses asperges sont moins présentes
c'est pas con on a fait autre chose
hélas est ce que vous êtes à la
recherche d'une nouvelle recette d'un
nouveau plat est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose que vous n'arrivez pas encore à
faire que vous travaillez avant de le
mettre à la carte mais qui vous l'a dit
à qui vous travaillez toujours basse et
sincère ce moment on est en train de
travailler sur un vous parce qu'on a
trouvé un vous exceptionnel du limousin
est on en train de travailler parce que
j'ai envie de le faire avec des
capucines cette fleur qui est qui
sublime mais les capucines c'est un
gouffre donc quand on fait une sauce
avec c'est un goût fabuleux en fait et
donc l'arrivée la capucine avec le
printemps l'arrivée du veau j'essaye de
coordonner ces serial ce mariage des
deux choses est effectivement en allant
dans quelques quelques jardins autour
quand on est allé voir quelques éleveurs
pour le monde on s'aperçut qui avait pas
mal de capucine donc là et comment ça se
passe la danseuse dans ces cas là vous
êtes à côté de votre cuisine et vous
travaillez sur ses recettes vous faites
une première formule de recettes vous
l'a retravaillé 2 jusqu'à ce qu'elles
soient complètement abouti à vos yeux
pour la mettre à la carte c'est un long
procès sous pas ça prend du temps alors
parfois alors je voulais je vous dis
parfois ça tombait comme ça et puis on a
certains qui ne tombe jamais en fait sur
les grilles qui a été la première on
n'arrive pas la transformer
on ne fait que ce qu'on a décidé de
faire en fait on cherche pas dire je
vais faire du veau je vais le mettre
tant pis maintenant quand on a abouti la
recette on la met à la carte si elle
n'est pas aboutie on la met pas la carte
et c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours en
train d'essayer et j'allais dire même le
jour où la recette est totalement
totalement finie on enlève de la carte
en fait parce qu'on va on va ne va faire
que moins bien donc on va là on va
éveiller c'est comme une recette est
comme un plat qui mijote sur le coin du
feu on va soulever couvercle on va
tourner et on va regarder on dirait de
soins ou à la durée elle peut revenir
une deuxième saison pas exactement mais
souvent avec un ingrédient
supplémentaire ou avec une vision
différente parce qu'on va la patine et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à atteindre
l'excellence c'est en
en travaillant
perpétuellement sur les recettes que
l'on fait et vous vous êtes seul maître
d'aidé car tout vous en discuter aussi
avec
votre votre équipe
alors seul m oui et non ceux de m parce
que on propose
c'est moi qui décide ce qu'on va faire
et après je travaille avec mes
cuisiniers avec sylvain au grand
restaurant et frédéric dans les autres
se dire voilà et ont travaillé ensemble
sur l'élaboration d'une recette seveau
capucine c'est quelque chose que j'avais
envie de faire on a une cuisson qui sur
le vous fait partie des 1000 ajouté
moderne ce qu'on essaye de faire en
restant s'est conclue il vaut sur des
coques de noix
quand je vous parlais de
d'environnement quand je vous parlais
culture j'ai toujours voulu moi associé
dans ma cuisine des très bons
ingrédients avec ce savoir faire qui est
le savoir faire particulier de la
cuisine française simplement que
vous le voyez aujourd'hui ce que j'aime
manger mais je peux pas le servir dans
mon restaurant donc je me suis servi de
ça pour créer les mijotés moderne pour
moi la cuisine c'est mijoter simplement
que ce qui me réjouit aujourd'hui avec
vous va pas réjouir mais convives au
grand restants et je me suis aperçu que
ce qui était bon dans la cuisine c'est
quand ta cuisine prenez du temps à cuire
donc mijoter simplement que l'époque
dans quelle envie nous donne pas le
temps de laisser mijoter comme ça et
forcément on n'a pas envie de manger une
blanquette de veau un boeuf bourguignon
tous les jours
il me manquait tu sais quoi c'est du
veau avec différents ingrédients qui
vont créer un goût le goût de la
blanquette qui n'existe pas dans la
nature c'est la réunion de tous ces
ingrédients là et dont je suis partie de
ce principe là en réunissant dans un
environnement différent ingrédients qui
sont pas forcément des ingrédients
habituels des coques de noix avec du
veau pourquoi parce que les coques de
noix vont créer un coussin de
température au fond d'une cocotte donc
au lieu que le veau touche la cocotte il
va être plus haut il va cuire tout
doucement on revient on me jeter les
coques de noix en tord et chiant elles
vont apporter un groupe qui n'existe pas
dans la nature dans la nature la
blanquette ça n'existe pas dans la
nature donc on est sur le même chemin
mijotez moderne donc le vous aidé cui
sur des coques de noix et qui apporte en
fait vous impliquez ce goût là qu'est la
singularité que j'essaye de d'imprimer
au grand respect donc pour répondre à
votre question ça c'est moi qui l'ait
qu'il est mis en place c'est moi qui le
dit l'un primes et après on va exécuter
par voilà après on le sait faire et ça
suffit comme ça bon vous êtes un coach
dont je serai pas le cierge paypal avec
vous on va passer au quiz à présent
alors jean françois piège vous avez une
impressionnante collection d'ouvragés de
cuisine à des originaux attention hein
le cheval jours auprès de plusieurs
milliers combien mais en combat ah ouais
plusieurs milliers oui j'ai même vu près
de 10000 par ailleurs il faut deux
pièces bon enfin c'est pas le sait pas
plus etes-vous incollables j'en suis sûr
que oui sur l'histoire de la cuisine et
des grands chefs qui jean françois piège
a inventé la sauce béchamel à mme
marquis de béchamel
alors c'est pas tout à fait ça c'est le
marquis de nointel
de son vrai nom louis de béchamel mais
non alors ça c'est la première fois que
ça nous arrive
voilà les réponses
attrapé nous parce que vous c'est sûr
que c'est que d'après le dictionnaire de
référence litres et qui se cache
derrière cette définition qui jette avec
voracité dans sa bouche ce qu'ils
mangent à le gourmand b le gouffre c'est
le goulu des le glouton alors là je ne
lisais pas depuis lors à son
expérience avec vos clients vous avez eu
des goûts infra table des goulus des
moutons et des gours ben
non il fallait bien qu'on vous prive la
rue bien piégé merci merci merci
lecointe au hasard alors non non le goût
et le goulu le goulu qui jette avec pas
nous c'est une petite erreur mais
mélange j'avoue qu'à vous bon ben ça
peut être qu'ils sont pif ou je sais pas
quoi c'est pire que le boulou vous vous
êtes beaucoup en contact avec les
clients vous vous allez les voir à leur
table le soir comment ça se passe on
fait même le grand restaurant et une
particularité c'est qu'on rentre par la
cuisine donc le premier bronze jours que
les clients ont vent restaurant c'est le
bon jour des cuisiniers donc la porte
d'entrée arrive dans la cuisse et un
couloir qui sépare évidemment pour des
raisons d'hygiène mais dont 40 par le
restant est la particularité c'est qu'on
invite les clients à venir déguster
quelque chose avec ma cuisine comment
passe devant en fait on a eu ce regard
quand j'ai fait tous les clients
tout ce qu'ils veulent on leur propose à
tous pour l'instant il n'a pas beaucoup
j'imagine donc c'est un business en plus
et d'une gestion plus oui mais en fait
c'est ça la halle quand je parle de
singularité en fait je pensais que les
clients les soulever venir nous voir et
on s'est aperçu que la salle est juste
après la cuisine c'est une cuisine mon
passe devant mais qui n'est pas ouverte
sur la salle elle est juste pourtant les
elle est juste à côté
elle est au début de l'exploitation on
ne faisait pas ça et en fait on s'est
aperçu que les clients ne se levait pas
donc de mon envie première qui était de
dire on a envie de partager un moment
avec les clients ils vont venir avec
nous on n'y arrivait pas vous qu'on n'y
arrive pas naturellement on l'a
organisée donc ils viennent déguster en
ce moment c'est un céleri qui pousse en
ile-de-france qu on fait cuire entier et
compresse pour ne garder que le
concentré du céleri un jus de céleri
pure on l'a fait avec des champignons de
paris et on graisse avec un petit peu de
gras foie gras et donc ils viennent
déguster ça avec nous on leur serre et
ça permet d'échanger il ya autour le les
oeufs qui vont servir on a des yeux qui
vient de normandie d'une ferme qui est
assez incroyable sur des poules de races
anciennes qui font très petites
productions c'est qu'ils cultivent leurs
céréales ils peuvent les apercevoir pour
leur dire qu'en fait on n'a rien à
cacher on est parent ce total oui puis
ça permet à la sangle a permis ce mot ça
permet d'être d'échangés en fait et
c'est ça qui va créer un sentiment
différent dans le restaurant parce que
il ya une multitude de très très bons
cuisiniers de partout sur la planète
mais ce qu'on pourra pas nous prendre
ces moments qu'on va échanger le lien le
lien qu'on va créer alors vous le savez
mieux que quiconque le repas occupé une
large place dans la dans la vie des
français et c'est souvent autour d'un
bon plat que se nouent les meilleures
histoires c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé jean françois
piège de réfléchir à une anecdote une
histoire autour d'un repas pourquoi pas
en politique ou autre est ce qu'il ya
une qui vous est revenu
oui il y en a eu des commandes et dans
un
bâtiment nationale et j'ai fait mon
armée à l'elysée je me suis dit qu'il
fallait tirer sur longueur au plan cul
planqué pas que un
facteur mais c'était très agréable
j'avoue que c'est un oui très agréable
parce que si une maison fabuleuse au
niveau de la cuisine oui parce que vous
étiez déjà le cuistot à l'époque c'était
votre dans ce cadre là que vous étiez à
lévis dans ce cadre-là
de cuisinier et c'est une maison qui
respecte l'identité française
parfaitement et elle seule doit mais
c'est bien de le rappeler en fait parce
qu'en fait tout est normal au bout d'un
temps tout est normalement l'elysée en
termes de cuisine je parle pas de
politique évidemment c'est quelque chose
qu'il respecte l'identité française de
la cuisine et les gens qui évoluent dans
cet environnement à l'époque ce le chef
c'était jouable moment il ya eu
guillaume gomez c'est maintenant il ya
un chef qui lui a succédé c'est des gens
qui sont passionnés par la cuisine
française
c'est normal à l'elysée mais rien n'est
normal dans la vie c'est pour ça que
vous le soulignez petite anecdote
j'étais cuisinier l'elysée était
organisée différemment qu'aujourd'hui à
l'époque il y avait une cuisine privée
qui s'occupait que du président en
dehors de
d2 la cuisine officielle qui est de
s'occuper du président pour les repas
officiel et donc j'ai eu
l'extrême honneur d'être dans l'es21
président il ya de nombreuses années
maintenant
voilà et le chef était absent il y avait
rien de prévu au déjeuner ça devait être
j'ai à dire
11h58 11h57 c'était tout fallait fallait
servir et donc il y avait toujours
quelque chose qui était organisée parce
que c'est une maison tout est organisé
mais rien n'était comme il y avait rien
n'était écrit et le secrétariat appel et
demande
le président va déjeuner à midi qu'est
ce que vous avez prévu pour le président
il y avait toujours un choix il choisit
ses deux entrées un poisson ou une
viande et je me souviens
on n'avait pas écrit parce que rien n'a
été prévu le chef n'était pas là il
s'était absenté pour un quart d'heure il
fallait répondre immédiatement donc
c'est moi qui ai écrit j'ai fait une
faute d'orthographe et ce qui était au
demeurant général pas très grave parce
que comme c'était organisé le
secrétariat ressaisissent et sur un
papier qui donnait au président là c'est
le papier que j'ai écris moi de ma main
il a été livré délivré et j'ai fait une
faute artichauts junien d&g vous savez
comme à l'école j'ai eu une petite une
petite un titre et dessus et de la
maintenance à mitterrand voilà le garde
et j'espère garder ouais vraiment mais
c'est au plus profond de moi et donc et
en plus barrés avec un thé à côté comme
à l'école donc cette petite anecdote
mais c'est comme ça qu'on apprend de
toute façon c'est la cuisine ça prend du
temps des erreurs je pense que beaucoup
de choses dans la vie on apprend en
faisant des erreurs allez maintenant on
va parler du guide michelin vous savez
que chaque année bien c'est la guerre
des étoiles pour espérer être
récompensés bien les chefs se mettre en
quatre c'est le dessous des plats
le guide michelin qui vient donc de
publier la liste des heureux élus alors
parmi eux frédéric calmels il vient de
décrocher sa première étoile au favori
c'est aux sources de cheverny dans le
val de loire les propriétaires alice et
jérôme tourbier ont voulu faire de ce
domaine d'exception un haut lieu de la
gastronomie française reportage
stéphanie des pierres gilles lepeytre
l'étoile ne figure pas encore sur la
plaque pourtant le favori vient tout
juste de décrocher son premier macaron
ce restaurant gastronomique est situé
sur le domaine d'un hôtel de luxe à la
lisière de la forêt de sologne en
cuisine l'étoile est évidemment dans
toutes les têtes le chef frédéric
calmels brief ses équipes pour le
service du soir on fait attention parce
qu'on a une personne qui est
complètement végétarienne au menu quatre
ou six plats avec une carte très axé sur
les légumes et les herbes ce soir en
entrée il y a c'est le céleri accompagné
d'un bar de ligne
d'un bar de linky juste un petit peu
marine est fait il est servi cru mariné
à l'huile d'olive
accompagné d'une sauce
d'une sauce à aigre douce des petites
connotation asiatiques après avoir
longtemps travaillé comme adjoint dans
les cuisines étoiles et des palaces
frédéric calmels ça enfin gagné sa
propre étoile au favori il ya tout ce
qui compte c'est le vous la présentation
ça représente des sommes de travail
importante on passe du temps à faire des
essais du temps à
mettre au point des recettes mais après
voilà c'est pour
le favori a ouvert il ya seulement six
mois ses fondateurs s'est élancé dès le
début dans la course aux étoiles on
s'était mis dans la peau d'un étoilé
quand on a ouvert au 1er septembre 2021
et donc on ne change pas les tarifs et
le chef la cuisine les équipes vont
faire évoluer les plats mais au gré des
saisons c'est plutôt les produits qui
vont dicter nos changements plus que
cette très belle nouvelle une très belle
nouvelle qui leur vaut la reconnaissance
d'autres grands chefs à l'heure des
difficultés de recrutement elle devrait
aussi permettre à jérôme tourbier
d'attirer de nouveaux talents et de
garder les siens car tout doit être
irréprochable
tous les jours de l'entrée au dessert de
la cuisson au dressage c'est une belle
récompense
en si peu de temps
tout le monde n'y a pas droit et on
travaille dur pour ça ça met un peu la
pression pour suivre un petit que
l'exigence que nous nous sommes imposés
maintenant et on a pu voir les rats
grâce à cette 1re étoile le favori est
désormais sur la carte de france de la
gastronomie cette étoile michelin nous
fait vraiment gagner des clients le
téléphone sonne depuis le 22 mars d'une
clientèle notamment locales qui
connaissaient pas forcément l'existence
de l'établissement et donc oui oui ça a
donné une visibilité pour des amateurs
de gastronomie bonne table parce que
c'est la dénomination une étoile c'est
bonne table une semaine après il est
encore trop tôt pour mesurer précisément
les faits première étoile en moyenne un
restaurant qui décroche le célèbres
macarons gagne 25 % de clients en plus
jean françois piège vous venez de voir
ce reportage c'est la consécration
d'avoir des étoiles pour tout cuisinier
c'est vraiment le but ultime recherché
alors ce qu'il décide pas ce qu'on peut
on peut faire la cuisine sans avoir des
toiles donc ça c'est ce qu'il décide moi
je sais que j'ai six restaurants dans
les restaurants ils sont pas tous
destinés à voir des étoiles le grand
restaurant est destiné à voir des
étoiles les autrement mais vous vous
avez toujours voulu en avoir vous avez
travaillé pour ça c'est c'est difficile
alors c'est une question qui est ambigu
parce que faut-il travailler pour ça la
réponse est non pourquoi parce qu'on
travaille pour nos clients on travaille
pour leur faire plaisir et c'est le
guide michelin qui décident d'attribuer
ou de ne pas attribuer des étoiles sauf
qu'en fait il faut être quand même dans
un lieu particulier il faut avoir je
suis athée à toutes les arts de la table
haute ou je ne sais pas ça je sais pas
vous répondre c'est plus le hac elle il
faut que vous avez pas conditionnement
quand même il faut on est on est là
conditionnement le conventionnement
c'est quand on raconte une histoire moi
je sais que j'ai organisé maison la
cuisine que je fais à la poule au pot je
pourrais pas la faire ailleurs parce que
c'est un restaurant qui a 100 ans on est
dans un contexte et ce restaurant la wii
non mais il est fait pour faire un
bistrot le restaurant que j'ai fait aux
grands restaurants c'est une partition
personnelle on rentre par la cuisine oui
c'est quelque chose qui est différent
est-ce que mais c'est pas on retrouve
pas la même chose dans l'assiette c'est
de la haute gastronomie n'en a pas assez
roulante c'est quoi la haute gastronomie
c'est quoi la haute gastronomie la haute
gastronomie c'est d'être singulier c'est
d'avoir une proposition qu'on voit pas
retrouvé au coin de la rue et on peut
avoir deux étoiles avec une blanquette
de veau
alors ça c'est pas moi qu'il faut poser
des questions mais je pense que si elle
est incroyable oui je dans l'histoire il
ya des il ya des gens qui font qu'il
fallait que l'on cuisine très classique
traditionnelle ce qui est l adn de la
cuisine il ya j'ai un livre des années
70 ce qui s'appelle les princes de la
gastronomie
c'est le canard à l'orangé il est dans
tous les trois étoiles de france mais
pour revenir sur ce que disait brigitte
est ce qu'on n'est pas quand même quand
on est chef et qu'on vise des étoiles à
peu conditionné on se pose pas la
question mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont
aimer question des tendances comment
réagissent aujourd'hui les les nouveaux
maîtres du michelin on se pose pas
toutes ces questions et on essaye pas un
peu d'être en phase avec un peu les
codes du michelin forcément ça c'est là
vous occupe ça à l'esprit alors réagi ça
je pense que c'est l'erreur à ne pas
faire un essai peut-être l'erreur dans
lequel on peut tomber quand on est un
peu plus jeune moi je sais qu'en
l'occurrence me concernant j'essaye pas
de réfléchir à ce qui va plaire aux gens
de chez michelin j'essaye de réfléchir
de ce que j'ai envie de dire dans un
restaurant de raconter de raconter c'est
pour ça que je vous parlais de la poule
au pot je peux vous parler de tout mais
restaurant si on parle que du grand
restaurant c'est ce que je pense de
meilleur après c'est eux qui juge une
cuisine singulière ce à dire qu'il doit
vraiment ressembler au chef doit être
différent qui ressemble qui doit qui
doit être différente mais qui doit mener
aux mêmes enfin et un seul but quand on
va au restaurant c'est prendre du
plaisir et se régaler que ce soit dans
un restaurant qui n'a pas des toiles ou
dans un restaurant cana 3 je pense que
le but d'un restaurateur d'un cuisinier
de quelqu'un qui oeuvre dans un
restaurant c'est donner le maximum de
plaisir moi dans ce que je fais aux
grands restaurants à travers la la c'est
pas une mise en scène mais là l'idée de
mettre en scène les territoires de
france avec les mijotés moderne c'est ce
que je pense de mieux dans la
gastronomie
pour le guide michelin ça vaut deux
étoiles j'espère que ça en vaudra plus
mais ça c'est eux c'est eux qui dessine
c'est pas c'est pas le sujet le sujet de
de se dire quand on a vu le reportage on
voit bien le jeune chef qui est
préoccupé parce qu'il à 7h de la stresse
autour des étoiles nuit après faut la
garder une fois qu'on l'a non voilà la
charge mentale des étoiles non on avait
les cheveux ce zune pass si oui mais la
charge est la charge mentale elle et
elle est allée à chacun a la charge
mentale de savoir je peux vous dire que
après ce qu'on a vécu après le coc vide
je pense qu'on a une charge mentale plus
importante que les effets du co vide le
des étoiles donc la charge mentale elle
va situer ailleurs mais quand par
exemple vous vous avez deux étoiles au
restaurant vous vous faites tout pour
les garder j'imagine fins et ses flux de
la mention fait tout pour aller plus
haut en fait où aller plus haut on fait
tout le mieux possible et c'est eux qui
décident après nous avait mal dormi la
veille
je dors toujours très bien méchant mais
je dors toujours georges dor vous savez
non mais la nuit qui sépare non je ne
vais pas dire je vais en perdre je
regagne non c'est vous êtes complètement
abstraction de ça
aujourd'hui dans ma vie dans ma vie
personnelle aujourd'hui le mes
restaurants sont quelque chose
d'extrêmement important le plus
important c'est pas mais restant c'est
ma famille ça il faut d'abord remettre
l'église du village les restaurants
c'est important on a failli tout perdre
il ya plusieurs mois donc on va quand
même pas se mettre la rate au
court-bouillon pour savoir
avec ce qu'on vient de vivre je pense
qu'il faut voilà faut relativiser si on
parle simplement des étoiles les étoiles
elles sont faites là pour certifier une
prestation moins ce que j'essaye de
faire que ce soit à l'épi d'or à la
poule au pot au grill ou aux grands
restants c'est le mieux à chaque fois et
c'est eux qui décident eux ils ont
décidé que ça va les deux étoiles ça
vaut deux et l on peut y avoir des
considérations aussi bassement
matérielles mais c'est vrai que déjà ça
motive les équipes quand même d'avoir
des étoiles c'est une forme de
récompense de reconnaissance
internationale et puis derrière ces des
clients plus c'est ce qu'on entendait
aussi dans ce reportage de téléphone
sonne sans cesse
je sais pas vous répondre parce que si
on prend en restant chez moi qui a pas
des toiles et les grands restaurants ils
ont un taux d'occupation quasi dans
quasi identique et parfois il y en a un
qui sera un petit peu plus plaint
parfois c'est l'autre il n'y a pas de
vérité je pense qu'à l'instant on ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'il a des étoiles
a raison et fonctionne parce que
l'équipe qu'il anime avec son
propriétaire avec ses son équipage ont
une volonté de faire plaisir aux gens
qui poussent la porte et de raconter
quelques de raconter une histoire c'est
à dire que globalement dans si on fait
un peu de un feedback dans le passé il
suffisait de faire bien à manger le
restaurant était plein aujourd'hui on
sait qu'un restaurant la nécessité
d'avoir une identité cette identité à
lily est soit un patrimoine classique
soit un patrimoine régional soit une
identité qui a été créée par ses
concepteurs et ça c'est ce qui fait
qu'un restaurant fonctionne ou pas il ya
beaucoup de restaurants qui n'ont pas
des toiles qui sont plaint quand même
mais pour avoir tout ça il faut souvent
être adossé à un grand groupe avoir des
moyens pour avoir justement un
restaurant un peu original est-ce qu'on
peut réussir à être étoilé sans avoir
quand même un peu de sou derrière
bien il ya sept ans mon épouse et moi on
est allé à la banque on a ouvert notre
premier restaurant on est 100 % chez
nous on a sept restaurants il y en a
cinq qui nous appartiennent 2 on est où
c'est moi qui si la carte mais c'est pas
la même chose du mozart mimosas et
clover gordes donc c'est pas moi qui les
exploitent les 5 restants qui sont les
nôtres on les exploite ils sont 100 % à
nous pardon en à 100% de la
responsabilité il il appartient un peu à
la banque parce qu'elle a fait des
victimes on a fait des crédits qu'on n'a
pas fini de rembourser mais non je crois
pas et vous parliez des étoiles face à
ça c'est à vous de décider est ce que
quelqu'un qui est adossé un groupe où
quelqu'un qui ne l'est pas
regardez les palmarès et c'est comme ça
que vous apprécierez ou pas la nécessité
qui permet d'avoir des étoiles ou pas je
crois pour moi les étoiles ça doit
rester la cuisine la grande cuisine
n'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
qui nécessite beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
moi je fais
je fais au grand restaurant une ré c'est
pas le poisson plus onéreux mais on la
choisit de petit bateau et c'est pas
moins jugé mais c'est très mal elle est
pas mal elle est pas mal c'est ça en
fait
le luxe nécessite probablement d'être
adossé à un groupe le sentiment et la
grande cuisine ne nous forcément va pas
forcément mais c'est deux choses il ya
la cuisine de luxe et et la cuisine de
sentiments et d'auteurs ça c'est gratuit
le sentiment est le fait d'avoir sa
partition ça coûte 0 c'est juste qu'on a
au plus profond de soi alors un bon
repas c'est aussi malheureusement la
garantie de quelques calories en trop
alors vous genre france souhaitait je
vous avez été confronté à ce problème de
poids de régis vous avez fait un livre
qui s'appelle 0 gras mais le gras est il
vraiment mauvais pour la santé on en
parle on met les pieds dans le plat
oui brigitte dans cette période où le
mieux manger et tendances faut-il
diaboliser le gras ou au contraire en
faire l'éloge et défendre ses vertus
avec votre livre 1 0 grâce à jean
françois piège vous avez choisi votre
camp mais vous allez voir pas que non
mais vous allez voir qu'il existe encore
pas mal d'accros aux charmes du gras et
des graisses reportage d'hélène manduel
et d'andré la faune
le grain c'est la vie sans gras il n'ya
pas ne sont pas de croustillant pas
d'odeur pas de
cuisine parole de présidente de
l'amicale du gr aujourd'hui faig nous
emmène dans cette institution parisienne
bonjour
la du terroir cuisine française
traditionnelle
ici la gourmandise est le maître mot et
le gras sont alliés à côté du canard
colorée à l'huile ou à neutre voici les
fameuses pommes de terre de la maison à
l'art on va venir y ajouter une bonne
dose de beurre demi-sel de baratte
normand et on va pas on va pas hésiter
avec la quantité de grains et ont de
manière à les faire rôtir mais surtout
faut pas hésiter
200 g de pommes de terre pour
250 g de beurre pas de doute ici la
gourmandise est assumée effectivement on
va pas manger c'est à tous les repas
tous les jours et tout mais moi la
cuisine que je propose dans mon
restaurant et les gens qui viennent
manger ici c'est pour manger debout gras
gourmand et défaisant les gens n'ont pas
l'habitude finalement canard aux olives
de challans ainsi que les pommes de
terre rôties au beurre demi sel et sans
surprise le plat est validée par la
présidente de l'amicale du gras il
suffit de relire le livre de patrick
justice les parfums
s'appelle l'amflora ge quand on veut
capter la room des fleurs ça passe par
le gras qui vont récupérer ses arômes là
c'est la même chose
ce jus la viande ou télé non franchement
c'est une cérémonie dont ce centre de
formation pas question non plus de
bannir le gras au contraire ici on
apprend à l'exploiter comme dans ce
cours de cuisine moléculaire
les exercices du jour pour ces futurs
professeurs de cuisine réaliser des
huiles infuser en fait ici on a deux
préparations on en a eues avec des
anchois et une avec des oignons et
toutes ces matières là ont infusé dans
de lune
cette huile en fait on va la récupérer
parce que les molécules aromatiques qui
sont solubles dans l'huile vont migrer
en fait dans cette huile pour retrouver
un goût prononcé qui va nous rappeler
ici c'est la pissaladière le thème
captez les arômes grâce au gras
en réalité tout est une question de
chimie et d' équilibre et puis le gras
le corps on a besoin ce chercheur
spécialisé dans l'alimentation
l'enseigne régulièrement dans ce centre
de formation dans le gras on a les
vitamines qui sont liposolubles qu'on ne
provoque que dans la matière grasse donc
en tant que tel ça reste des vitamines
mais c'est dans la matière grasse
qu'elles vont se mobiliser donc c'est en
mangeant 4 intègre à ce qu'on va voir la
vitamine à la vitamine d la vitamine e
sont absolument essentielles pour notre
métabolisme ne faut surtout pas laisser
véhiculer ce message comme quoi le gras
et poivrons c'est pas vrai lebrac est
essentielle et il suffit juste de savoir
lequel est dans lequel quantité apport
en énergie en acides gras ou encore
fabricateurs d'hormones le gras est donc
indispensable à notre corps le cerveau
par exemple consomme 20 % des calories
que nous ingérons chaque jour
alors jean françois piège question
provoque le gras c'est la vie ou la mort
tous les jours ça peut être la mort et
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cet ouvrage
c'était pour dire que quand on a envie
de bénéficier d'un apport en gras assez
important lors d'un repas qui peut être
un peu plus riches on à la nécessité le
lendemain d'avoir un repas plus
équilibrés et pour ceux qui veulent
cuisiner plus équilibrée c'est pas un
livre de régime c'est un livre qui peut
même sur un plat assez simple donné
beaucoup de plaisir et vous pourriez
manger ses pommes de terre vous ah oui
tous les jours et bâton c'est ça c'est
ça qui a changé dans la nourriture c'est
que cette cuisine qui était très riche
qu'on mangeait probablement tous les
jours parce qu'on avait une activité
physique qui était différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est quand
même
descente à d'un sédentaires citadins ont
nécessairement envie d'une cuisine qui
est plus légère on peut pas manger comme
ça tous les jours donc la vérité elle
est ou dans la cuisine est léger il y en
a jamais qu'une il faut mais on était
vraiment plaisir entier à 0 gras c'est
vraiment et il ya vraiment du goût parce
qu'on dit que le grave que vous posez
une question oui asperges c'est la
saison ouais j'ai inventé une cuisson
qui est rentré dans les mijotés moderne
en réfléchissant à cette cuisine là je
prends vous vous rentrez ce week-end
vous le faites c'est basique vous prenez
des asperges blanches ouverte où les
éplucher vous prenez un plat un plat qui
va au four gratin vous cuisez du riz 11
minutes un rib basmati quand il est
chaud voulez goûter vous le verser sur
les aspects que vous avez légèrement
salée par dessus des asperges par dessus
ouvre on les voit en lui comme cissé il
met à plat donc ne s'en remet pas
beaucoup il va y avoir à peine 300 il
est chaud quand vous le mettez sur les
adjots le four vous l'avez préchauffé à
180 14 minutes vous sortez les asperges
c'est la plus belle cuisson d'aspères ce
que vous allez avoir votre vie vous
allez me dire mais j'espère je n'ai pas
oublié on n'est pas obligé de les cuire
avec du gras mais en fait c'est cette
réflexion de faire une cuisine sans gras
qui m'a amené à trouver certaines
cuisson ou mais souvent on est pas mal
de sauce avons fait une petite
mayonnaise avec des lyonnaises j'ai fait
j'ai fait
de la gélatine c'est ça un bouillon de
légumes gélifiée a les mêmes goûts
franchement on n'est pas loin il suffit
vous savez quoi j'ai dans ont fait à
manger aux clients dans nos restaurants
mes collaborateurs se font à manger et
j'aime bien que dans ma maison mange
bien parce qu'on peut pas penser à faire
bien à manger aux autres si on mange pas
bien soi-même
et quand j'ai fait cet ouvrage donc on a
fait les recettes et ils ont goûté la
sauce césar de la volaille qui étaient
cuites avec cette sauce qui était sans
gras qui était à fahem par d'enquêté
fait à base de fromage blanc aujourd'hui
quand le soir on était il décide de se
faire une salade césar ils font pas la
recette traditionnelle pour la recette
du livre et c'est pas moi qui leur ai
demandé alors vous réhabiliter c'est
bizarre pour je rebondis sur ce que
disait brigitte comment faire sans
graves ou réhabilités l'eau dans la
cuisson oui souvent l'ol est un peu
justement à ses détracteurs dans la
cuisine faut pas faire bouillir les
légumes dans l'eau il faut pas les faire
trop cuire dans l'eau parce qu'ensuite
ils vont prendre cette eau donc vous
vous arrivez à
aller faire cuire à l'eau sans les
mettre dans l'eau sans les mettre dans
l'eau voilà sans les médias elle est là
qu est à l'eau au lieu de l'évacuer au
gras c'est sa réaction en fait quand on
cuit on va cuire des navets si on a de
l'eau alors nous on prend pas de l'eau
du robinet qui a un goût de chlore on
prend de l'eau filtrée où on prendre
l'eau minérale en prendre une casserole
on va mettre des navets qu'on a épluché
un tout petit peu de sel et on va mettre
le quart de cette eau là et tout de
suite on va mettre un couvercle le sel
va proposer provoquer l'excitation des
légumes donc tous les minéraux des
légumes vont tomber dans la casserole
avec très peu d'eau tout de suite ça va
caramélisées on va rajouter au fur et à
mesure un tout petit peu d'eau et on va
les cuire dans ce jus donc en fait parce
que l'irak dans l'oise c'est à dire que
si on prenait 3 lido conclure il avait
effectivement ondées l'aftout del rey
n'a que etc mais là à la fin de cuisson
il n'y a rien mais est-ce qu'on retrouve
le nacre ajout le laquage du petit
n'avait caramélisées avec dürer et et
jeudi soir l'aide de prendre le lien en
bas c'est le vôtre
je pense qu'on va le voir là il ya que
du sel et des navets alors évidemment je
vais pas tomber tout de suite dessus
parce que sinon ça serait pas marrant
cette émission n'était pas préparée non
mais voilà mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant en fait c'est la profitation
qui permet de se dire que faut quand
même je tombe dessus un moment donné
parce que ça devrait serbe est gênant on
va essayer avec brigitte à moi je
meubles a on va essayer c'est que ces
petits navets ça vous tente pas ce que
tu ressens un peu caramélisé with c'est
vrai que la facilité d'en commettre du
beurre et du sucre pour caraméliser des
navets je suis tombé sur les endives ah
c'est bien aussi basse vallée est ce que
les environs ont l'air d'être cuites à
l'eau non mais là c'est les chartes de
la photo non c'est vrai qu'elles n'ont
pas l'air endives braisées son sens en
matière grasse sans matière grasse et
elles sont faites avec un jus d'orange
qui va donner un petit peu de sucre de
caramel et le sucre il est à l'intérieur
de tous les temps tous les légumes
pourquoi quand on fait un régime on ne
mange pas les légumes qui poussent sous
terre parce qu'ils contiennent tous pas
mal de sucre on mange en général les
légumes verts et encore pas tous parce
que certains contiennent beaucoup de
sucre mais il suffit de réfléchir c'est
pour ça que l'eau ou bouillon de légumes
qui va servir à cuire surnommé des
petites quantités on va avoir une
concentration du goût et on va
caramélisées et on va arriver à avoir un
résultat qui est quasi identique
mais en drap amis de beurre on n'aura
pas mis de sucre comme il pense pas
parce que je vous ai entendu plusieurs
fois parlé de sel on compense pas en
mettant un petit peu trop de sel non
parce que le sel en fait n'est qu'un
révélateur de saveurs et qui va donner
l'assaisonnement j'aime pas la cuisine
qui est trop salée moi j'aime la cuisine
qui est juste le salé et vous mettez du
coût des herbes un peu des pis aussi
pour redonner un parfois parfois parfois
pas nécessairement pas nécessairement
parce que je pense qu'il ya des choses
qui sont intéressantes d'être mangé plus
tôt de façon nature et puis en a
d'autres qui sont intéressantes quand on
les mange qui sont extrêmement
assaisonner alors une bonne que ray
est-ce qu'il faut pas beaucoup de beurre
voilà n'est pas obligatoirement être
c'est un tel état obligatoirement des
noms qu'ils avaient fait une purée 000
grands ont fait par exemple à mimosas
une pomme de terre écrasées à l'huile
d'olive je lui donne attendait la bonne
purée comment comme on imagine on est
d'accord c'est robuchon ses 250 g de
beurre pour jour
pour 250 ventes de motos vertes et oui
ce lundi c'était dalida quasi identique
et ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup et
205 et c'était bon mais c'est tout c'est
très bon alors je
m'étais d'huile d'olive c'est du golf
alors elle c'est pas le même grâce et
pas les mêmes normes est caractéristique
de gras on a on a donc si on calcule les
calories on a autant de pommes de terre
que doué et en plus on rajoute du lait
de la crème donc les rues on est
extrêmement riche les pommes de terre
qu'on fait les pommes de terre écrasées
à l'huile d'olive c'est des pommes de
terre montagne qu'on a épluché qu'on a
cuit dans de l'eau mais mesurée mans
évidemment l'eau qui recouvre la
totalité des pommes de terre mais qui va
pas lavez les pommes de terre une fois
convaincu les pommes de terre on va les
sortir on va les écouter on reprend une
fourchette entre les écraser on va
prendre l'eau de cuisson qui a été
parfumées par les pommes de terre
et on va arroser d'huile d'olive et
quelques herbes fait ça je peux vous
dire vous allez vous régaler et pourtant
reculé de 5 en garde pas moins de
calories l'astuce est que pour mouiller
vos pommes de terre il n'y a pas que de
l'huile c'est le bouillon qui permet
aussi d'apporter les invités autrement
que de l'huile et on est mort et c'est
là où on va revenir quand vous me posiez
la question tout à l'heure cette recette
là elle n'est pas de moi elle est dans
la chapelle c'est un chapelle qu'un
fameux cuisinier
des années 80 et 90 ce qui aujourd'hui
disparu qui était à mios nié dans la
bresse qui faisait sa purée de pommes de
terre avec l'eau de cuisson mois 7 c'est
ce qui m'intéresse dans les livres c'est
la culture ça veut dire quoi c'est que
mon prochain livre qui va sortir dans
quelques semaines c'est pas 0 gras 0 oui
c'est zéro viande et 0.0 poisson qu'est
ce qu'on va manger chez piège maintenant
s'il ya plus de gras poupées les livres
c'est parce qu'on vend chez moi c'est ce
qui est en fait je donne la recette
d'une purée de légumes
vous pourrez légumes c'est quoi souvent
c'est des légumes conclu à locon mixer
auquel on rajoute du beurre non on fait
en sorte de cuir des légumes dans très
peu d'eau pour que toute l'eau et tout
ce qui est qui a été transféré dans
l'eau soit dans la purée et que je ne
sois pas bouillante pour qu'elles ne
brûlent pas mal
ça comptait aller mais le péché mignon
on pas ce dessert
j'ai déjà fait
qu'il est temps du sucré et là encore un
choix modeste de votre part jean
françois piège sans ostentation une
simple tarte aux pommes pas un desserte
palace mais plutôt de boulangerie mais
je pense que ce qui vous plaît d'abord
dans cette recette c'est son aspect
basique une bonne pâte et 2 bonnes
pommes ça fait forcément une tarte extra
je me trompe pas jean françois piège
n'est ce pas sans compter que les
variantes sont infinies alors pour vous
qu'est ce qui caractérise la tarte aux
pommes et qui vous fait relever la nuit
pour manger une bonne tarte aux pommes
c'est qu'elle soit très cuite à les
femmes des deux en fait parce qu'une
pomme cuite on va concentrer en saveurs
une pâte cuite qu'elle soit feuilleter
brisé sucre et sablé ou celle qu'on ait
choisi de faire ce qui va être bonne
c'est qu'elles soient croustillantes et
donc pour qu'elles soient croustillantes
c'est cuit est ce que vous avez remarqué
depuis tout à l'heure vous m'interrogez
que tous ceux tout ce dont vous parlez
tourne autour d'une chose et mes
réponses sont là même de la cuisson
parce que métier de cuisinier c'est le
métier de cuir c'est pour ça que moi au
grand restaurant j'ai décidé de mettre
en scène les territoires parce que ce
qui est la richesse nationale est
importante mais pour qu'elle rejoigne et
la crise en est la cuisson et c'est ça
la conclusion alors une bonne tarte aux
pommes sur une tarte fine et vous mettez
rien sur la pâte moi j'aime bien complet
c'est ce que disait léonard de vinci la
plus grande sophistication c'est la
simplicité c'est pas totalement ses mots
mais c'est ce que je pense qu'une tarte
aux pommes c'est de la pâte et des
pommes peut-être un peu de beurre un peu
dessus s'ils vivent dans ce qu'on veut
et puis revient pour vous c'est vous
dites cuisson c'est important mais il ya
dans la cuisson il ya la durée on vous
dit longtemps mais il ya aussi la
température donc votre tarte aux pommes
un nom facture moyenne ni l'un ni
l'autre abu il ya que le résultat oui
oui alors votre tarte si je vais faire
la tarte et là jean françois piège et
qu'il n'a fait que très longtemps mais à
quelle température alors là tant la
cuisson c'est un couple
et je vais vous dire vous allez
comprendre un couple temps température
on augmente la le la température on
baisse le temps on baisse la température
où on augmente le temps une fois qu'on a
compris ça dans la cuisine dans si vous
l'accusez très chaude elle vous
l'accusez pas lent que voulez vous faire
dire c'est que longtemps elle cuit moins
fort exactement et voilà ce que vous
avez en tout cas ce que vous avez
compris cg mais qu'on prenne son temps
parce que le vrai luxe en fait c'est pas
d'avoir dans la cuisine des plafonds
dorés le vrai luxe c'est de prendre le
temps de faire plaisir aux autres et
prendre le temps de faire plaisir aux
autres quand on est dans la cuisine
s'est passé du temps pour leur faire
plaisir passer du temps à cuisiner et à
cuire alors vous ce qui vous fait
plaisir quand vous regardez la
télévision ou un film c'est de regarder
le grand restaurant de ses références au
début d'un vol parce qu'effectivement
moi j'ai immédiatement pensé au film de
louis de funès et je ne savais pas au
départ que c'était lié en fait au nom
vous avez donné de manière très toilé
alors la raison non non c'est pas ça 6
mais la raison c'est que le film a
permis d'appeler bon restaurant parce
que évidemment le grand restaurant c'est
prétentieux
c'est une discussion un jour adhérer
quand on cherchait le nom de de ce
restaurant qui est allé à qui allait
arriver qu'elle est calé ouvrir
on prend d une feuille on met des noms
est ce qu'on appellerait comme ça comme
ça comme ci comme ça et mon épouse me
dit allez courage de l'apec en restant
je dis oui grâce au film et oui parce
que c'est moins prétentieux que vous
allez comprendre pourquoi restaurant
parce qu'en fait
quand j'étais plus jeune on avait eu
quelques fois dans des restaurants
gastronomiques peu souvent et c'était
une vraie sortie et on allait dans un
grand respect et en fait quand j'ai
regardé les noms qui étaient employés
s'étaient souvent les patronymes des
propriétaires du chef ou d'une histoire
qui était lié à l'endroit où se trouvait
au lieu mais jamais
le le nom d'un grand restaurant et quand
j'ai une pâtisserie j'ai appelé gâteau
parce que je trouve que l'évidence c'est
la chose la plus simple et comme aucun
restaurant gastronomique ne sapent les
grands restaurants on a décidé de
l'appeler en restant et le film m'a
permis d'avoir cet humour aussi du
deuxième degré c'est le 2e degré qui me
permettait de filmer sa voix est
effectivement alors vous savez qu'on
termine toujours cette émission en
musique vous avez choisi celle là on les
écoute ensemble
mettre un genou à terre sur qui
[Musique]
elle est pas belle et bonne c'est à
jeudi un homme très bonne voilà les
golden ce qui était la peine sur les
pommes très longtemps elles ont passé
elles peuvent pas aussi se déprendre
cécité un peu non ça dépend si c'est un
four à sole ou un fort rp c est parce
que pour une bonne tarte fin pour un sol
parce que le la chaleur
alors bénabar c'est ce que vous écoutez
régulièrement dans les cuisines chez
vous dans la voiture
alors bruno bruno d'abord ça c'est mon
copain
aussi pour ça que j'ai choisi parce que
la vie elle est faite de rencontres
d'amitié donc c'est mon ami est ce que
j'aime aussi c'est qu'ils cultivent
comme moi cette identité française dans
son expression
et
sans élan nationaliste d'être français
quand on est en france est une nécessité
moi je quand je vais à l'étranger je
veux découvrir un pays dans ma cuisine
dans mes restaurants si vous venez chez
moi vous allez découvrir une partie de
la france qu'elle soit plaisir petit
bout de france voilà végétal dans clover
green à gordes provençal et aux grands
restaurants plus singulières et lui il
raconte la france souvenez de ces succès
le dîner je veux pas y aller bas on cela
s identifier avec ses paroles il y met
dans ses chansons des choses de la vie
et c'est sa vie quotidienne la vie
quotidienne de son avis simple ordinaire
et moi c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
dans mes restaurants j'essaye de
raconter culturellement un pays à
travers ses paysans ces éleveurs et
autres et effectivement le savoir-faire
de cuisinier que je suis alors vous nous
avez donné envie d'y aller donc
n'hésitez pas si vous voulez vous aussi
allez chez jean françois piège le grand
restaurant cover greencopper grill et
tous les autres beaucoup bien sûr la
poule au pot l'oni moselle merci jean
françois piège c'est vrai mais avec nous
d'avoir partagé ce repas merci h et
france ô à ce qu'ils nous accusent in et
ses bons petits plats de lait cru bon
voilà très bon voilà c'est le chef qui
le fera quand même merci à vous et tous
deux avoir suivi à la semaine prochaine
sur lcp
même quand ses revenus
jamais
thomas
nous disons non
or
si le groupe m6